la alerta se emite en toda la ciudad de
niguita en el oeste de Japón como medida
de precaución los residentes están
refugiando en búnkeres dicen estar
preocupados por los constantes
lanzamientos de misiles norcoreanos Es
realmente aterrador al principio querías
esconderme debajo de la mesa con mi hijo
no puedes tomarte esto a la ligera
pensando que todo va a salir bien
la alerta se produce un día después de
que pyong yang lanzara una oleada de
misiles Corea del Norte disparó 23
misiles en un solo día una cantidad
mayor que en los dos últimos años entre
los tres últimos cohetes había un misil
intercontinental cuyo lanzamiento al
parecer fallo Japón condenó
inmediatamente la agresión norcoreana
el lanzamiento regular de misiles
balísticos es absolutamente indignante e
intolerable
por su parte Corea del Sur ordenó a su
vecino que deje hacer lo que llama una
provocación él continuó lanzamiento de
misiles balísticos por parte de Corea
del Norte es una grave provocación que
amenaza la seguridad y estabilidad no
sólo de la Península de Corea sino
también del mundo también es una
violación flagrante de una resolución
del Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
condenamos enérgicamente estos actos e
instamos al norte a que los detenga
inmediatamente este aumento de los
lanzamientos se produce en un momento en
el que Corea del Sur y Estados Unidos
están llevando a cabo las mayores
maniobras militares jamás realizadas que
Corea del Norte ha pedido suspender en
respuesta los simulacros se prolongarán
hasta el fin de semana